- I think it's gonna be like,
the PG version of my favorite snacks.
(electronic music with drum beats)
- In small text, it says
"Enlarged to show texture."
- What is this, brownies for ants?
- These are dog treats.
- I don't know if my dog
would even like this, though.
- Yo, this tastes like space food.
- They taste like chemicals,
but decent chemicals.
- A mixture between delicious
chocolate and paint.
- Does that look like the
inside of a brownie to you?
- This is just a gateway to sadness
and ultimately, emptiness.
(buzzer sounds)
If this brownie was a celebrity,
it'd be Tom Cruise, standing on the couch
professing his love to Katie Holmes.
Even though, we all know
it's a contract marriage.
- [Woman in Gray Shirt] I love these.
- Oh, thanks for the
big dose of nostalgia.
- This one's already giving me the farts.
- It's just like, what
happens to your balls
after you don't shower for four weeks.
- It's still good.
- If this was my first time trying this,
it would be (beep) disgusting.
- It's pretty delicious,
it's just buttery,
baked, cheesy goodness.
- [Woman in Gray Shirt] Ew! Okay.
- Well done, food scientists.
(bell dings)
- I would say, maybe, Britney?
No?
- What?
- It's not good for you, but you know
it's gonna be delicious, and
you know just kids love it.
It was like Katy Perry's
Super Bowl half-time show.
- Oh no, this is so bad!
- Where is the cream?
- I don't like when people change Oreos
from their natural form.
Put them in a pentagon,
and hexagons...
- I'm out.
(chair legs screech)
- This ain't a (beep) Oreo.
The (beep) is this (beep)?
- Do we have anything, like
gasoline, to wash this down
so I can get this gross
taste out of my mouth?
(buzzer sounds)
- This, to Oreos, is
like that "Home Alone"
sequel that didn't have
Macaulay Culkin in it.
- Right?
- You can't just put the name on it,
but it's a completely different thing.
- Off first smell, pretty good.
- I can do it.
- I feel like Keebler was
never really my thing.
- Yeah, who the (beep) likes Keebler?
- I love me some Keebler.
- Yeah, I love Keebler.
I'm really into this.
- I actually might like these
better than the original.
- It's sort of like a cracker
with a tiny bit of chocolate on it.
- This would be a great laxative.
- I would eat these for dessert
if I had nine bags of them.
- If I take your 10 cookies,
they make a cookie, just eat a cookie.
- But isn't it better--
- Just eat a cookie!
- I want 10 cookies, I
don't want one cookie.
- You could have been making
money, or making changes,
but instead, you were poppin' 10 cookies.
- Do you think I need to make changes?
(bell dings)
- It's like P Diddy in that,
it was really cool when you
were young, and then now,
you have the grown-up version,
and not as cool as it used to be.
- I have never seen the ingredient list
for anything require two columns.
(girl laughs)
- There's a lot of variety in it.
It's fun.
- Obviously the way it tastes
is, it tastes like a Cheez-It.
- It's good, it doesn't taste like
the non-hundred calorie version to me.
(bell dings)
- [Man with Dark Shirt] This
tastes like Maroon Five.
- Maroon Five! Yes!
Adam Levine is this Cheez-It.
And then all the other guys are probably
really talented musicians,
and they're like really good.
- But you don't recognize them,
at all.
- You don't know who they are!
- I personally would like
the people of America
to just eat food, and
stop worrying about it.
Just eat the food.
Just eat the food!
- Oh yeah, Americans really
need to eat more food
and stop thinking about
their health, good message.
- Do you guys want--